What's up guys, Jared,
here to talk about the most buzzworthy cinematic contribution of 29.
[Inaudible].
I obviously mean joker.
Now we expected that a film spotlight in comic book Laura's most iconic
super-villain would crush at the box office.
But what we didn't expect was that the director of the hangover part who would
be so central to the politicals EIT Geist,
but one of the most interesting things about joker is that while it clearly
resonated strongly in 2019,
so much of the film borrows from past cinematic traditions.
And when you parse through the copious references from film history,
you'll find that they're all drawing from approximately the same time period.
That is the mid 1970s to early eighties. That's not us being evil geniuses.
Todd Phillips has said.
Watch, but it was really a group of movies and, um, a time of movies. So,
so I would almost argue that it's, it was movies from 1973 to 1981.
There's a ton of movies that influenced this film.
Quick caveat because saying the phrase movies made between 1973 to 1981,
a takes forever, and B is boring.
We're just going to broadly refer to this time period as seventies cinema.
So forgive us for the slight fudging.
Now the seventies were an objectively cool and complex time for movies,
and we're constantly repping the era in our videos. Still.
We've been wondering why is jokers so preoccupied with this era of filmmaking?
Let's find out in this wisecrack edition on references in joker and major
spoilers ahead for a film that you and a hundred million other people have
already seen. Also older movies like taxi driver and the King of comedy.
So let's dive in Phillips.
His seventies vibe is evident in every frame of the film from the gritty
establishing shots of Gotham to the impressionistic angles of Joaquin's
interpretive dancing.
But that inspiration also manifests pretty heavily in the movies themes,
which is what we're going to be focusing on today.
Now Phillip's vision board is so crowded with themes from this era ranging from
class conflict to the cult of celebrity that we could be chatting until the
inevitable joker sequel arrives in theaters.
So in the interest of not missing happy hour, we pick the three,
we find most interesting part one bad guys in the 1970s,
the antihero reign Supreme and antihero is basically a morally ambiguous
protagonist who would probably sell out their own mother for a decent old
fashioned. Now the seventies were deep in the era of new Hollywood,
a period that began in the mid 1960s and was defined by bulldog tour directors
like Robert Altman, Francis Ford Coppola and Stanley Cooper.
These guys in their cohorts may daring films like medium cool dog day
afternoon, taxi driver, five easy pieces, Harold and Maude,
any hall American graffiti and so on. According to scholar David Thompson,
while films of the previous decade featured naive and liberal revolutionary
notions and harness the era's optimistic energy films of the early seventies
became confounded by actual experiences showed the moral bankruptcy of the
established order. Yes,
you don't have to be a film scholar to see why movies turned grimly cynical.
This time period was basically defined by post Vietnam war despair and anger at
the establishment. In 1972,
that cocktail of misery was coupled with outrage over Watergate and ensuing
disillusionment with the government by night, 10 74,
just 36% of Americans trusted the government.
That meant movies about flawed bro worlds and deeply cynical characters.
Fittingly. That also meant the rise of the anti-hero or that almost always male
protagonists, who is complex and deeply flawed.
Sometimes beyond the point of redemption. These characters make shocking,
morally ambiguous choices from taxi drivers, Travis pickle,
who commits a heinously violent act to save a child victim of sex trafficking to
the King of comedies Rupert Pupkin who takes a famous comedian hostage in order
to score some decent airtime for his own stand-up act to dog day afternoon,
sunny ward sick,
who tries to Rob a bank in order to acquire money for his partner sex change.
While none of these acts jive with our general collective morality,
we're still able to empathize with and understand the reasons behind each
character's actions,
but from the mid seventies and on largely due to one mechanical shark and a
certain galaxy far, far away,
Hollywood became increasingly reliant on unsure fire blockbusters.
And with some exceptions has remained that way pretty much ever since in recent
years, that's meant an increasing supply of IP driven content.
Specifically those reliably successful comic book movies.
Most of those are inspired by superheroes from the golden era of comic books who
typically represent moral rectitude. As a result,
these stories are typically pretty black and white about morality.
You have a hero and you have a villain, they Duke it out. The hero wins, hooray.
Sure your Spider-Man or Ironman might make a mistake or learn a lesson or
overcome an unfortunate flaw.
And no one's trilogy certainly shows its protagonist grappling with some moral
issues. Still. For the most part,
they're unlikely to make an Uber morally questionable choice like Travis,
Rupert, or sunny.
This brings us to joker the first Hollywood film to laser focus on the
super-villain Phillips takes this big budget opportunity and uses it as a
vehicle to revive the seventies,
ethos of a complex character in a doomed society,
turning Arthur Fleck into a character that obliterates are easy distinctions
between good and evil.
Like many of these seventies heroes Arthur is flawed complex and to varying
degrees sympathetic. But by subbing,
this seventies archetype into the context of a comic book, film,
Phillips subverts, the superhero genre and challenges,
the typical simplicity of its morality.
There's also another level of subversion to Phillips is also using a mainstream
Hollywood film as a sneaky vehicle for reviving the seventies.
That is the last real golden era of independent filmmaking before Hollywood
became a pipeline for big budget action films and hangover sequels he's dropping
mainstream studio dollar bills to depict the challenging morality of these
gritty independent films and to reflectively comment on and complicate the comic
book, film genre, pretty cool part too fantasy versus reality.
One of Joker's defining features is how it bends the distinction between fantasy
and reality.
This dramatic tension also appears in some of our favorite seventies films.
Most notably the film's biggest inspirations Martin score says these films,
taxi driver and the King of comedy. Many people have pointed this out,
but joker borrows copiously from both films, for example,
in Joker's best homage to the King of comedy,
it casts Robert de Niro as a famous comedian.
Exactly like the one played by Jerry Lewis opposite a young DeNiro.
How do you, how do you do it? I think it's that I look at my whole life and I,
I see the awful,
terrible things in my life and turn it into something funny.
I just happens. But what about the first few one-liners?
Were they strong enough? I wasn't strong enough. No, they run as strong.
You had hurt yourself. That model is your Debbie bastard like.
Comedy's Rupert.
Arthur also has delusions of finding a father figure in said famous comedian and
when rejected lashes out violently and in Joker's Besto Mazda taxi driver,
it depicts Arthur as sharing Travis's inordinate fascination with guns.
Hmm.
In a delightfully dark touch,
Arthur and his neighbor even mimic Travis's iconic finger gun to the head,
possibly as if to indicate that like him,
neither of them have anything to lose both taxi driver and the King of comedy
feature outcast characters with pretty bleak lives going through tough times
only to conclude with their greatest wildest dreams.
Realize Travis becomes a celebrated hero precisely because of his violent
vigilantism.
And he gets hit on by his dream girl to boot while Rupert becomes a world famous
comedian, precisely because he took another comedian hostage.
These two outcomes are improbable at best and completely delusional at worst.
That's why both are also frequently interpreted as being pure fantasy in taxi
driver.
Travis kills multiple people with an illegally purchased firearm and doesn't go
to jail,
but rather is valorized the King of comedy frequently transitions into fantasy
sequences and the improbable ending could read like one of those.
So despite score says, he's occasional protest.
We to read each film's conclusion as the desperate imaginings of a troubled
character with only the most tenuous grasp on reality,
but beyond the superficial plot or character references, Travis and Rupert,
each emerge as a remarkably appropriate blueprint for a character like the joker
who is notorious for lacking any semblance of a stable, reliable pass.
We talk about the Joker's ever-shifting origin story extensively in another wise
crack addition,
but here's the too long didn't watch of jokers and scrutable past and Alan
Moore's the killing joke.
Jokers portrayed as a failed comedian who had one bad day that turned him very
bad later. We learned that joker. Isn't even sure if that backstory is true,
which would make crafting his LinkedIn profile, particularly in contrast,
Christopher Nolan's joker is a pathological liar who seems to ad lib the truth
for his own amusement.
You want to know what got these scars?
My father was a drinker.
So I had a wife like you.
Most intriguing comic writer.
Scott Snyder gave us a joker who uses his mysterious origins to manipulate those
around him. Fittingly.
This includes posing as a psychiatric researcher working on his own report,
which he fills with tragic tales of childhood abuse.
I did my best to help come up with the story you wanted, the one you needed,
the grim and grimy tale of woe.
The one a publisher would lay down six figures for viewed in this light,
aligning joker with the also unreliable perspectives of a Travis pickle or
Rupert Pupkin makes a lot of sense.
It actually underscores the fact that we could take the entire movie with a
grain of salt. In fact, joker could almost be read as either a,
an imaginary Snyder style sob story cooked up by the joker himself,
fallen Arkham asylum,
or B an imaginary delusional tale of the Joker's rise to folk hero,
much as Travis's newspaper clippings or Rupert's memoir were for them either
way. It gives this lasagna of a film, a whole extra layer,
but there's another interesting aspect of the fantasy reality dichotomy in all
three of these films,
the deep isolation of the central character leads them to fervently pursue the
affection of a beautiful inaccessible woman. In the two score says he films,
the men's ensuing short-lived court ships are painted as real and painfully
awkward in joker. Arthur also harbors an unrequited love for his neighbors,
Sophie.
He takes her out on a fun date and even get some after committing his first
murder psych due to imagine the whole thing. In fact,
he doesn't realize until he shows up uninvited at an unsuspecting Sophie's
apartment,
a clarifying montage shows us that unlike Travis or Rupert's fledgling
relationships,
Arthur's budding romance existed only in his deeply troubled mind.
The thing about all three of these women is that they are the unlucky objects of
these three men's fantasies,
projections of their desires to find love beauty and a merciful end to their
tragic isolation, except in joker.
This romance is literally imaginary as if, well,
literally the extent of these three men's delusional projections in this way,
the film seems to argue that no idealized love story could save Arthur or Travis
or Rupert from their own rage,
pathology and above all intolerable loneliness.
Part three media sensationalism.
This brings us to another important theme that joker shares with many seventies
films, that of media sensationalism. Now we delve deeply into the influence.
The 1976 film network had on joker in our quick take joker and the politics of
recognition,
but network also reflects rather presciently on the way sensationalized media
can completely transform public perception in network news,
anchor Howard Beale goes off the rails and decries what he sees as a deeply and
broken society.
We know things are bad, worse than bad. They're crazy.
It's like everything everywhere. He's going crazy. So we don't go out anymore.
And he threatens to commit suicide on the air.
His crazed rants resonate deeply all across America.
As people take to their windows to scream at nobody.
Particular.
News executives, seeing the power of Beall's anger,
continue to spotlight him and plan even more sensational media.
The film argues that people who are emotionally and spiritually disillusioned
with a broken system can be very easily swayed by the forces of mass media,
which direct our attention to whatever story is currently sexiest or in our day.
Cliquiest the ease with which Howard attracts a fervent following suggests that
our desperation to find truth and meaning can lead us dangerously astray.
Particularly when it's in the monetary interest of TV executives,
what's more network shows the shrewd way.
The simple act of widespread media coverage effectively turns a very unstable
Howard into a martyr reframing his objectively concerning suicide oath.
As a positive act of courage.
We see the same effect at the ending of both taxi driver and the King of comedy.
Whether you read them as imaginary or real,
Travis is celebrated status as a hero,
suggest the power of the media to reframe a society's moral outlook while
Rupert's post crime rise to celebrities suggest that a media spectacle can as
with Howard turn any audacious act and do something worth celebrating.
Similarly dog day afternoon shows the way an opportunistic media will gladly
transform someone like sunny and adult bankrobber into a folk hero for a
compliant thrill seeking.
Public.
Joker. Similarly features no shortage of commentary on media sensationalism.
After Arthur kills three wealthy Wayne employees,
the media transforms the anonymous clown into a figurehead for Goffman's
impoverished masses,
a natural opponent of the revered Thomas Wayne excessive and sensational media
attention bloats.
The importance of Arthur's act turning him like Sonny and Travis and Rupert and
Howard from mere criminal or madman into a full hero.
As in the other films,
the masses comply and Arthur becomes the unwitting leader of a political
movement.
He doesn't care about Arthur's political apathy underscores the arbitrary nature
of mob mentality and just how beholden we are to the choices the media makes
about its coverage. Though,
the film is set in a Gotham akin to an early eighties, New York city jokers.
Shrewdly adapts the themes of these films for the intensified media climate of
our day today's internet hive mind can conjure literal mobs to storm top secret
government facilities or Duncan children,
or more in the passing of the world's most dignified gorilla. Similarly,
the fervor for which Arthur's actions are covered by the media effectively makes
him like Heran Bay, a folk hero,
the violent mob that coalesces around him projects their own rage onto his
violent act and view it as a call to arms media spectacle film tells us
distorts the truth and misdirects our emotions.
There are those who would argue that just as media attention,
valorizes Arthur flecks actions for the people of Gotham,
it does the very same thing for real-world audiences,
uniting them behind a violent,
dangerous symbol of the mocked and disenfranchised.
That's why no discussion of joker is complete without mentioning the requisite
media controversy that surrounded his release accusations that the film would
encourage violence or validate dark audience impulses were widespread,
perhaps fittingly,
both of its two main inspirations taxi driver and the King of comedy also
experienced their own varying degrees of backlash.
Taxi driver had to make some edits to its climactic scene in order to skate by
with an R rating and was partially blamed for motivating an assassination
attempt on president Reagan.
The King of comedy also had its share of naysayers with comedian, Johnny Carson,
turning down the role of Jerry Langford out of fear of life,
imitating art and a healthy supply of negative reviews reiterated his point.
This isn't surprising films that basically forced us to empathize with
characters like Travis Bickle or Rupert Pupkin or Arthur Fleck characters who
make us grapple with morality reality.
And probably some other allergies that we don't have time to get into are always
going to be a lightning rod for controversy.
Ultimately though we think the way that joker thematically incorporated its own
controversial cinematic forefathers is worth mentioning and pretty cool.
But what do you guys think is joker and effective callback to seventies
greatness or a blatant rip off wearing a clown mask?
Let us know in the comments.
Thanks again to our incredible patrons for supporting the podcast and the
channel. Go ahead and click that subscribe button and as always,
thanks for watching guys. Peace.
[Inaudible].